[Music]
cause we were with you in Venice you
made the trip to Toronto now bouncing
around I'm curious you're moving you're
on the move is the family out here with
you
no they're in LA I have face time with
them a few minutes ago we're just gonna
say as a dad myself I kind of bounced
between feeling guilty as a dad and also
enjoying the night off from dad duties
work will I do every three hours hey if
I don't get up I feel guilty you know my
wife is up nursing every three hours so
it's a lot of work but it's fun man look
at you I feel great
I have to make decisions like what's
best for the family the difference for
you if there is one promoting film doing
the tour when you're you know been in
front of the camera as an actor versus a
director or it's a lot different as you
can imagine I don't have all of the
responsibilities of being in front and
you know having to worry about what
people think how you look and how you
know so it's a lot easier in a way not
to have to deal with it well on that
note your comments recently about being
past the leading man roles well you know
I think I think you have to you have to
look at your career over a long period
of time and figure out what's best you
know to do and I actually I'm looking
for different kinds of roles we keep
wanting to see you you know something
you gotta keep putting a softer lens on
the camera Angeles is no good anymore
yeah so the proper lens
[Music]
you